okay and it's movie reviewing time again
very similar to our review of the baby
cart series yeah this is actually kind
of gonna be a review of a whole well
part of a whole series yeah well
actually I think we can probably cover
pretty much all four movies the fifth
movie of James Bond they're making it
now and you really can't in detail cover
each plot or each one of these moves cuz
they're very complicated yeah I just
want to recommend this series of movies
the new Daniel Craig James Bond series
is so much better than the older ones
and I'm a James Bond fan yeah you are
there's a lot more to these movies than
meets the eye really you know you think
well you know on a show like 13 o'clock
why the hell would we bring up James
Bond of all things well there's a lot of
little occult knowledge and gnosis
inside James Bond there always was yeah
you're going back to Ian Fleming in an
interview in Ian Fleming was once asked
what religion does James Bond and he
answered Manichaean and a man at Cannes
ruin or Gnostics and there's a lot of
symbolism in occult symbolism in a good
James Bond movie now you know I don't I
haven't seen all James Bond movies I
don't know if they all had symbolism in
them but pretty much all of these new
ones do and that's kind of like true to
the source material I definitely feel
like the more recent reboot of the James
Bond series starring Daniel Craig
it's simultaneously a modern updating of
the character but is also it's close
back to the novel character that Ian
Fleming initially conceived it's very
true to the source material or the
intent of the source material Oh that'd
be probably a good way to put it the
guys that wrote these scripts and
directed these movies and they weren't
all written and directed by the st. P no
it was yeah it was generally the same
you know group of people but but these
these these guys here knew their [ __ ]
they know their Bob oh yeah yeah they
knew exactly what they were doing and
Daniel Craig if you asked me is the best
James Bond I think he's even soon
because they won't man but Connery nah
not really well and honestly the more I
read because I've been reading a lot
about all four of the movies because I
sure like what the critical receptions
of them were at the time because I don't
remember yeah I don't really care I was
saying that when Casino Royale came out
in 2006
I didn't realize but although initially
when Daniel Craig was first announced
that he was going to be the James Bond
the new James Bond I think Hugh Jackman
was kind of the only other one that
might have been which is even better yet
bond to everything but some people were
like well he doesn't really look like
the bond that he's not like tall dark
and suave the movie came out yeah
everyone was like oh yeah yeah that's
just he's like the best one and you're
not the only person that said that like
a ton a ton of critics said that okay
when Casino Royale came out it got
pretty much universal awesome reviews
like this is like everything everybody
wanted yeah I just know what you know
he's such a good bond and you know it's
it's like I said it's like an updating
of the character but it's also an homage
to the masked and I think people were
really really happy with it now when I
was coming up you know I was playing you
know James Bond double-oh-seven
Goldeneye on n64 some guys in there
laughing but everybody knows that firt
it was it was like one of the first
really good first-person shooters you
know I was into the Pierce Brosnan Bond
and Pierce Brosnan I thought at the time
he was a pretty good James Bond until he
took his shirt off because he did have a
he did have a good look to him yeah but
he's climbing on the side the trains
he's fist fighting all these guys and
his arms when I have it see his arms up
man I cook I cook we didn't quite buy it
you couldn't buy it all right now you
Daniel Craig his shirt I gonna go that
dude can whip some ass here's the thing
and again we're talking about the first
one in the series that came out in 2006
Casino Royale which has actually been
made it was made into a movie before it
was actually made into a TV show before
- like a TV episode before also so
something that they wanted to get back
to you they said the problem with the
Pierce Brosnan ones and no one
pierce brosnan he was a good luck he was
a good bond yeah but they said well the
problem was as his series of movies went
on because he was in four of them yeah
also that they became too reliant on
digital effects that there was too much
product placement yeah in fact Die
Another Day was often criticized as by
another day that's so much like obvious
product placement in it I think - this
was something interesting that Roger
Ebert said like comparison comparing the
new Bond films to the old ones he said
you know the Daniel Craig bond is the
first Bond films that actually seemed
like human people with human emotion
yeah human reactions it's like it seemed
like old ones were very superhero-ish
yeah very a little cartoony not they
were bad because I liked a lot of the OS
on films but they're the characters are
kind of cardboard they're more
caricatures and but that was long and
that was almost kind of the way things
were at the time I mean the the Daiya
style the Die Hard series was like that
and they has a very you know popular
series you know it was very much in line
with American action movies this was
like a British take on the American acts
ray with double-oh-seven as the hero and
it was they were kind of like the Marvel
movies of the day yeah I mean every
superhero wish but not the Daniel Craig
bonds the Daniel Craig bombs are I would
say a little bit more influenced by like
the Jason Bourne yeah born and like I
said you're not the person to make that
yeah accent but I really couldn't bind
that Matt Damon was doing what Jason
Bourne could do Craig though alright cuz
here's the deal Brosnan and Matt Damon
when you look at them you go those are
actors you look at Daniel Craig Daniel
Craig to me does not look like an actor
well he looks like an athlete slash
boxer yeah that's what he looks like
he's not pretty
no no but he's good-looking but he's
good-looking yeah and a rugged kind of
hot marked like he said like a boxer
like a fighter and that's the way but we
just scribe right in the source material
yeah like he's still sexy he's still but
he looks like a scrapper and if you whip
your ass right you know he and I said
that was a good choice James Bond was
supposed to be an ex SAS guy right you
know
was put into this intelligence a British
intelligence agency and he was a fighter
first he wasn't a model or an actor
right you know that's what Pierce
Brosnan and Matt Damon they look like
models and actors to me you know and
James Bond went too much of that
direction for the movies you know in the
movies right so they were had to take it
back to what the book said he was the
book said he was a soldier now Casino
Royale was awesome all right because the
meaning of the very is kind of like in a
way Batman Begins in the beginning of
the length of that the new Batman series
it was the movie was like the creation
of the bomb that you know and what bond
had to learn as a man or as an agent was
how not to kill he was a killing machine
from the very beginning yes and he did
not be they never actually played the
James Bond theme until the very end when
he did not kill a dude that he really
wanted to kill that's when he became Bob
all right and then from there on out and
all the other movies they would actually
use the James Bond theme song at certain
times and Casino Royale they didn't yeah
until the very very end and I love that
well because like I said Casino Royale
because this was coming off you know a
whole reboot of the series so they kind
of wanted to showcase how Bond got to be
Bond how he got his double-oh-seven how
he got his yes to kill and how he was
still kind of inexperienced yeah but it
was that was kind of like the character
arc and then at the end of the movie
they're like okay he's arrived yeah and
now we can go on from there and it also
kind of had the whole thing with Vesper
Lynd you know the woman that he loved
and yeah she betrayed us and then
there's a bunch of symbolism in there
the she frey actually said that um the
cipher and the bad guys in all these
movies are not overpowered bad guys
they're cogs and a bigger machine they
have their own network of bosses that
they have to answer to and there's a
bunch of stuff happening
mi6 knows from the very beginning that
there's some kind of organization acting
from the shadows that they don't even
know what it is or
it's called eventually in the movie four
they realized that all these villains
they've been dealing with are all tied
together and they work for this
organization called Spectre or they call
it Spectre and it's kind of like the
forces of corruption you know some
people might call it you know depending
on who you are you know terms like the
New World Order or globalists or
Illuminati but all those kind of terms
are not accurate for what is really
going on Spectre is a really good term
to describe what it is that they're
fighting against and they're fighting
against the forces of human corruption
in the elite class it's a place where
corporations NGOs politicians
intelligence agents where they all kind
of merge into this mafia this global
mafia that uses information and dirt on
each other to control each other it's
kind of like a a mafia of favors between
criminals they're true believers they
don't even really believe in money money
they're so rich that money is not
motivating them and they make that clear
in the very first movie I want to spoil
it if you haven't seen it but it's made
clear in the very first movie that who's
running the show doesn't really care
about money they just care about what
you believe and it was awesome
the interesting thing though about
Spector and we're kind of getting a
little bit ahead but that's not is well
the interesting thing about Spector is
that the first couple of movies were
actually not intended for Spector to be
I mean they were not written that way
originally because Spector the
organization which I believe and please
correct me if I'm wrong I think it was
introduced in the in fleming novel of
Thunderball now for many years there had
been legal contention so the James Bond
series could not use the term Spectre
and fight for this so they kind of had
to fight for that one day and when they
of got the rights to that name back
they retcon okay awesome of Solace to
make it seem like it was the same well
organization which I actually didn't
know because really when you watch all
four movies because we watched them
her like a two-day period and they go
together a lot better than I realized it
is a very seamless the first hand movies
are all the movies are very seamless
they use the same cast and even the same
cast of villains and from the very first
one though M does says something's
happening here something we can I see
and then the second one they also refer
to that there's basically there's more
here than meets the eye there's so they
were linked it's just that maybe they
couldn't state it from there very mean
way yes they didn't have a copyright on
the term Spectre they couldn't use the
word
right until I bet at Li the fourth move
because like I said they did I mean
Spectre was the villain in the villain
organization and Thunderball I think
yeah so they went back later and kind of
wrote it also like I said when you watch
them all in order
I'm actually really amazed that they
didn't conceive the entire thing from
the beginning but they didn't and
honestly a lot of the stuff that
happened I believe it was during Quantum
of Solace that was when that big
Hollywood writers strike was going on so
they had a first draft of the script but
they were not allowed to hire any
writers to like fix it or do any
rewrites so they kind of had to go back
and you know are getting like some of
the producers employed and some of the
actors input and like trying to get
something put together and the funny
thing is that I was gonna say when
Casino Royale first came out in 2006 the
first time I saw it I was actually on an
airplane yeah so you know which is not
the most ideal situation because the
screen is like five inches wide and it's
like plus I'm on an airplane which I
hate so I wasn't really concentrating on
it so I did I was just kind of like man
whatever then when I saw Quantum of
Solace it didn't make much of an
impression now when we when Skyfall came
out in 2012 he was telling me we
actually saw that in the theater and I
was like wow this is really really good
there was a know like an amazing movie
so when you got all four of the movies I
said we need to watch all of these and I
actually liked all of them much better
yeah then I you know remembered yeah
what's too particularly when I when I
first saw them I was trying to rank them
I kind of put Casino Royale and Skyfall
ahead of the other ones with most
critics didn't Skyfall yeah the best one
yeah but but having watched them so many
times now I say no they're all about
equal they're different they're they're
offering different things but I like
them all about equal like for instance
um I used to think Quantum of Solace was
the weakest one but now I think it's my
favorite one it has a lot of weird
alchemical symbolism in it there's a
scene where you know bond is always kind
of like a fire a symbol and the Bond
girl is always like a water symbol where
you have you know energy and lust and
creation and fire you know and then you
have the water symbols which is more
about wisdom and remember he's hooking
up with a girl who is the Bolivian yeah
secret agent and there was kind of like
a love thing going on but they were very
different before they go into action
she's checking her weapons and getting
ready doing the wise things and he's
like [ __ ] it we're just gonna go in
there and you know take them out yeah
and they get in there and basically
they're inside of basically a castle
made of sand it's it's actually a weird
hotel built out of sand blocks built
from the desert that it's built in and
it's in a desert over a huge reservoir
of underground water and it's powered by
hydrogen so you have water and then in
the hotel the sand hotel or the sand
castle catches on fire so you have stone
being burned by water it's all kinds of
these weird alchemical symbols that I
don't fully understand I remember there
was an alchemist in one episode where I
talked about this earlier where he came
and he explained exactly what the
alchemical meaning was and if we have
any alchemists in the audience I'd like
to know exactly what it was but it's
basically what it was was a a castle
made of sand in a desert over an ocean
of water being burned by the water we
bond and the and the woman inside the
castle trying to fight for survival it
was some kind of alchemical meaning I
thought it was pretty cool well yeah and
actually on the on the Quantum of Solace
I believe Wikipedia page the director or
one of
or something like that did specifically
say her ther firewater theme okay okay
yeah she she's been doing it I don't
know this okay yeah I guess I could tell
it was on purpose
yeah I wasn't really sure exactly it was
a male female water fire earth wind air
all the LM yeah it was an elemental
thing yeah
and that was definitely the direction
they wanted that was pretty cool no no
another thing that was in there remember
is that when they get to Bolivia the
taxicab drivers speaking in Spanish in
there subtitles on the bottom he says
and he's an old man he says you know
basically saying that the spirit of his
grandmother is warning him that the
trial is not natural so so there's this
an occult message that I haven't really
totally figured out there's an occult
message to the may the Dead was trying
to speak to bond through this cabdriver
pretty weird but like I was saying I
mean the whole and I had seen I probably
seen over the years since I was a kid I
probably seen most of the James Bond
movies you know from the sixties to now
I always liked the series but it wasn't
a favorite of mine but I really do like
and this is kind of this you never see
this happen but this was like the
longest-running film series ever isn't
it the James Bond yeah because I think
when I think when Skyfall came out or
Quantum of Solace came out I can't
remember that was like the 50th
anniversary of dr. now or whatever so
for someone to take such a beloved and
old franchise and reboot it for the
modern modern era and have it come out
so well yeah I mean these are easily my
favorite Bond movies yeah and then do
get better as they go along to special
effects and yeah and the stunts they did
get better as they went on but there
easily and somebody wanna say it's
blasphemy to go against Sean Connery
Bond series
I think it's opposite oh yeah I do - I'm
gonna say look I love Sean Connery but
look and even somewhat some of those
movies were mediocre even Sir Roger
Moore yeah came out and kind of implied
he's like yeah I think Sean Connery
might have to move over a little bit
like when Casino Royale came out the
first Daniel Craig won just because this
was obviously a set of writers a set of
directors
Daniel Craig got all on board you know
he really
worked hard training he wanted to do a
lot of his own stunts obviously didn't
do the super dangerous ones but they
wanted to do they said we wanted to get
back to largely practical effects there
are some digital effects in it but we
felt like the Pierce Brosnan ones went
too far in that direction it was too
cartoony or like we wanted to get it
back into some realism while still
hearkening back to the old ones yeah
he's like also we wanted to concentrate
more he said what one thing we were
thinking about is that international
travel is not as exotic as it would have
been for you know people in the United
States or in Britain in the 60s so it's
like we wanted to still have that
element but we wanted to focus more on
the character there like because people
nowadays like them they like a more
complex character one that's not black
and white one that's morally gray and we
thought that was more interesting
speaking of black and white Casino
Royale opens with realism it's a black
and white flashback a how Bond got his
double-o and basically how he did what
he had to do to get his double-o was not
some glamorous act of brave it really
was not basically murdering a dude in a
bath - in a bathroom in the men's room
okay yeah it really affected him and
then the second one was a lot easier and
it condensed into a small flashback that
took maybe not even five minutes and
it's just an it's an awesome scene let
you know that this is not the James Bond
that you knew alright yeah and then then
when it shows the first color scene is
James Bond in action on a case and he
ends up in a big parkour scene where he
and so if the Kray leaves everything in
with cranes and jumping and going
through construction zones and Daniel
Craig and the guy that he's chasing her
extremely acrobatic and very very
physical and then the scene of shots
very believable so it's letting you know
that this is not a pretty boy bond this
is not an a model actor doing but never
gets dirty who never gets disliked
sweeping up right and everything yeah
and the scene ends with him executing a
dude which is just you know so it's not
the exam right now yeah this is not a
clean bond and the original
was not a clean bot this job was to do
bad things but to serve a better higher
purpose yeah to where you can do evil to
achieve good and that's where all this
you know Gnosticism came in they had the
original books a balance between east
and west black and white good and evil
you know somebody who's kind of above
that in a certain way and that's what
the meaning of all this is but it still
affected him yeah it's still affect and
that was one good thing that I really
like about daniel craig's portrayal is
that even though he comes across as very
steely very cold it's mental you think
he'll that it's affecting him mentally
face even though he's trying to get a
[ __ ] together everything that's happened
to him is affecting him but he's not
really it's indoors outwardly yeah
that's a good way of putting it he's
enduring it meant he gets hurt he stays
hurt he has to heal up but then the
wounds are still there he has to fight
these old wounds you know exotic bullet
fragments that are still lodged in him
from yeah from while ago mental scars of
the past having to avenge people that he
cared about and those people that he
cared about betray him but still he
forgave him for the betrayal is a bunch
of deep stuff go on and I really like -
I must say because I love Dame Judi
Dench yeah and I love that they really
expanded her role in this and really the
relationship between bond and M is
really one of the whole hearts of this
series yeah this new recent ribbon is
his mother face yeah she's like a very
maternal figure and M was his mother in
the original source material so that's
that's true to the material but there's
more than one M you'll find out later
what I'm talking about
that way some of the Connery era movies
are also honoured in this series and you
know like I said they did a lot of The
Times Casino Royale which pretty much
sticks close to the book Quantum of
Solace is actually a partially original
story they took the title from actually
an Ian Fleming short story but it
doesn't really have anything to do with
this story a lot of these are original
stories but that call back to some of
his novels and
aspects that were in his novels like I
said I should say that when they came
out when Casino Royale came out I
learned I wanted to say something though
about about Quantum of Solace Quantum of
Solace
to me was really cool because it's
talking about the quantum group the
quantum group owned an environmental
protection group in the movie that is
kind of like owned by the main villain
and it's just like something that Rosa
Cory talks about in the green mask it
was a book that a woman wrote who is she
was a woman who got involved with
environmentally who did environmental
protection stuff under the UN but it was
really more of just like a con it was a
way of stealing property from people and
selling the rights away to their friends
and governments it's bizarre but that is
some of the stuff that's talked about in
these movies was actually based on real
cases that happen and in quantum solace
it was basically corrupt environmental
protection as of course you know by
environmental protection is good you
have to protect the environment but when
you see the movie you see that you can
also use that as a mask to do to do evil
but anyway that whoever wrote these
stories wrote these scripts also is kind
of paying attention to things that
what's actually happening kind of like
you know behind the scenes in in the
shadows it's pretty cool well that yeah
the reason they set that whole Quantum
of Solace thing in Bolivia was because
it was based on an actual water revolt
that happened yeah so it was kind of
based on that which we had similar sort
of circumstances yeah yeah and a couple
of the later films in the series to kind
of get into the whole computer hacking
sort of yeah basically it's on my Google
well yeah or like you know global
surveillance type of thing but of all
four movies like I said when Casino
Royale came out in 2006 it was actually
the highest grossing Bond film ever at
the time until Skyfall came out in more
money actually Skyfall was the first
Bond movie to make over a billion
dollars guy thought was awesome
what Skyfall was all about was about
bomb fight in his shadow
turns out finds out that bond comes up
against a guy who was just like him
another double oh it's like the mirror
yeah he was another double O agent that
worked for em and and betrayed him
actually and he got captured and
tortured and he ended up joining Specter
and him and the forces of Specter go go
after em to get revenge and bond has to
stop this guy and this guy's just as
clever as bond if not and probably in a
way more powerful because he's not being
restricted by an agency he's just doing
it on his own in the name of Specter I
guess we know he's doing it in for his
own quest for vengeance but he's also
doing it in the name of Specter it's
pretty cool plus I love Xavier Bardeen
so yeah any party place he always plays
such a good villain of course he was in
no country for old man yeah like this
garys [ __ ] ever brought that hare and
the cattle gun yes so he plays the
villain in that one and like I said I
think of the new for movies and like I
said they're making an v one now we
haven't seen it yet obviously but can't
wait right so of these four I think
Skyfall is probably my favorite and it's
funny because I would have put Spectre
second before but now that I've seen
Casino Royale again I think I'm gonna
put that second Spectre third and quiet
you should try to read rank them but
it's hard it's hard to rank them because
like I said I fall is the easily that
Skyfall has the most superficial appeal
let's say if you're not super super into
the series if you had to just pick one
that was like really entertaining to
watch just because the cinematography
and the pacing of it and this the action
scenes and just the just the thrill of
the movie Skyfall would probably be on
the surface the best one for a beginner
to watch if you only wanted to watch one
of them I don't recommend it I recommend
starting from Casino Royale and just
watching them all but sky fall on the
surface probably the most fun to watch
for the first time on multiple viewings
I think they all start to compare with
one another real well when I first saw
Spectre oh but first when I first saw
spectrum the theatres in the theatre I
was mad because I have Chinese - Chinese
guys next to me that were just talking
to each other the whole time in Chinese
I think one of them was trying to
translate for the other one but I just
couldn't enjoy the movie you know and it
was packed and then I bought it on
blu-ray and I liked it a lot better but
I like Spectre - that was a
movie my favorite part of Spectre was
the opening with that long opening
sequence instead of the Day of the Dead
yeah I mean that was a beautiful
beautiful say Mexico man Mexico look at
Mexico City look really cool yeah that's
kind of the cool thing is that even
though this is you know you can use the
cliche gritty reboot or whatever but
it's still glamorous yet it makes even
like crappy looking places look real
like this yeah you know what I mean even
if something looks decayed and yes it's
still yeah but it still looked really
really amorous everybody dressed up for
Day of the Dead there yes and that whole
thing with the helicopter thing and holy
[ __ ] that's amazing and he's in bonds
there to assassinate a dude yeah in his
costume it's [ __ ] pretty cool but
yeah I think the coolest thing about
this like I said you you can watch these
movies are fine as standalone movies
yeah but when we watched all four of
them back to back man back to back like
over two days there's so much like that
they pick up from the older story you've
got to have a good memory for faces
because you really don't yeah that you
really don't get if you see them years
apart when they come out because some of
the bad guys are used over and over
again and it all ties together you don't
know their names but eventually you do
and then eventually they become major
characters you're like the dude from
movie one was actually like really
important to movie three and four is you
just have to get the whole arc of bonds
character from this kind of inexperience
at the beginning his betrayal by Vesper
Lynd you get you know his other
betrayals his relationship developing
with em and you kind of just get this
whole you know the introduction of some
of the other iconic characters in the
series as it goes on and you kind of get
a sense of his character arc and his
kind of roof you know what I mean which
is cool and you don't really get that
when you're just seeing them and one at
a time inspector was respect her which
is the newest one is still really
contemporary is still real relevant
today because in it it eventually
inspector they introduced the kid a
famous bond character of blow fell
Blofeld is you know he's not a pleasant
played a man
in the yeah in the other movies of
Donald Pleasant the scar on his ID and
that was the basis for doctor dr. evil
from Austin Powers a Austin Powers me
but Blofeld in this one owns a company
that is basically what they're talking
about it's Google and Google or
Blofeld's company I'm gonna use the word
Google but Blofeld's company is using
its power over elected officials to get
his Intel company major contracts with
all the nations of the world to replace
all of their intelligence agencies so
this is how low felled inspectors gonna
get rid of the CIA mi6 and all the Intel
units of the world so Specter can take
its place and dominate mankind they can
just watch everybody they through your
surveillance through your cell phones
and your Smart TVs and all the cameras
placed across Europe and Specter will be
the Intel agency and basically if you
you know if you know you know the the
history of Silicon Valley and Google you
know Google is merged with the Intel
agencies you know those Lockheed Martin
and many other companies but that's what
they're talking about
so basically Blofeld is kind of Bill
Gates type character and like a like an
evil Bill Gates really yeah I guess yeah
I guess that's what they're getting but
what I was gonna say is that I really
like the way they mirror the themes like
look at particularly inspector where you
know they're trying to introduce
something called the 9 eyes yeah that's
basically a global surveillance and
they're so with skin a fight we're gonna
fight terrorism and all this so and you
know there's this kind of shadowy
organization who are doing all these
terrorist things to encourage people yes
we need more yes surveillance so we can
prevent terrorism this terrorism attacks
that we did I like that one of the
arguments that they're making oh the
global surveillance you know it's the
21st century
field agents like the double-oh-seven
burger oh it's out of date yeah and I
like that they tied that in with bond
being all beat up from the last one and
he's like in and you so you're almost
feeling like personally he's beat up
he's been out he's getting older he you
know he comes back and
doesn't he can't pass his physical past
but MJ's in batch semental he can't even
pass the mental life but em kind of
skates and like letsa to go out back out
in the field anyway because she believes
in him and so I like that they tied in
this whole old-fashioned versus new and
then just made it this kind of
complicated complex thing that tied in
with what was going on with yesterday
cuz when you think about it what would a
traditional agent like double-oh-seven
how could he stack up against Google
alright yeah how could he stack up
against drone strikes yeah no but I like
that they acknowledged that they
acknowledge that you know the the type
of evil that they're talking about with
what the global surveillance could be
used for good also
yeah because of the character of cue and
I like that they introduced the
character of cue who was actually
introduced in Skyfall right yeah yeah so
I like that they kind of made him this
very young you know nerdy like a
computer programmer type of guy and I
like to that he's fast and he's focused
not too much on you know the gadgets you
know there are gadgets but they're very
little Eva bol gannets it's not just
like oh it's some cigarette that fires
it invisible cars like that which I
think the original series it did so this
one it's still everything you want from
a Bond movie you know there's exotic
locations there's crazy like
over-the-top action there's you know
gorgeous women but they updated it in a
way that doesn't make it seem like they
just updated it for updating sake but
they actually deepened the character
brought into the character made it more
realistic so so it didn't seem so much
like a cartoon or like cardboard yeah
and he does play those old James Bond
Sean Connery kata sexual innuendo games
with with women but they play it back
with them and they write there obviously
playing they're playing and they're
doing kind of like mental mental arm
wrestling games with each other because
it's between agents they're trying to
get underneath each other's skin you
know what you see and they'll use sex to
do it you know even villains did do it
because I think that was something I
mean not all of the old Bond movies were
like this but it
seemed like a lot of the old bond my
vision and they had the Bond girl they
were just kind of there to be pretty
they are there to be seduced by bond the
new ones I think is kind of more they're
not really like that yeah they're not I
mean they're beautiful and sexy and they
use sex to get they want sometimes but
they are also equal to him
yeah just is intelligent idea what their
job was right right and so I like that
they kind of had I mean not all of them
are badasses who knows that someone were
just accountants like members right you
know it was but they were mostly account
yeah some of them worked in offices you
know and one of the characters who
wasn't you know in Spectre was actually
a you know a doctor yeah they were all
just as smart as him but you know they
had different talents and I like that
they did that yeah they didn't really
take any [ __ ] from him and that's kind
of a specter was the h1 had special
talents like is she free he was you know
then the very first one he's just a
mathematical genius he could count cards
in a card game he could handle bank
transactions and he remember he did all
those like numerical yeah yeah head you
know but he made him almost unbeatable
of cards and then you know some of our
computer scientists the guy who ran a
quantum group just was a guy who could
smooth and use political propaganda to
his advantage she knows what I'm had
their own strengths and we and can we
just talk about I mean Mads Mikkelsen
you played lashya and seen her oh what a
scary dude that I love that guy is so
awesome his poker face was just
terrified I heard he's good and
everything but I really did like him in
this like all the villains in this were
really good yeah all of them are good
I'm like I like Christoph Waltz to
inspector was also very good but I liked
him and everything he's he's really a
good actor oh and can I just say I kind
of make a point of this right now being
a graphic designer all of the title
sequences of these new ones are gorgeous
yeah the Casino Royale being my favorite
I mean that is an amazing title sequence
I could just like watch that on a loop
forever
they're great like The Spectre ones
they're great motivation Ackles great
movies on a lot of different levels a
lot of symbolism a lot
cult messages and I'm a lot of political
messages philosophical messages
fantastic story writing
yeah I've been searching for my perfect
series movie series sometimes I say well
maybe it's the Back to the Future series
or you know maybe it was everything
Hills Cop now I actually kind of think
the Daniel Craig James Bond is the best
series out of all series for me just yet
that once he was in I really really do
like him and like I said I do recommend
that you kind of watch them all very
educational because what they did with
that character I mean this is a
character from you know a different era
yeah and the fact that they were able to
update it while still paying homage to
the original is really amazing and the
fact that they really expanded on the
mythos yeah and he really embodies that
character now the series actually just
shows that the British are kicking ass
over Hollywood if you ask me American
these guys can write they can act they
can shoot a film it has a very European
flavor to it but they've taken ideas
that kind of came from the air it kind
of came from the American action movies
never they've not only perfected it but
surpassed it this is just a dominant
series if you ask me it's just like I
said pretty much all four of the movies
in the latest series have made quite a
bit of money Casino Royale and Skyfall
were the highest rated both with critics
and they made the most money but also
but the other two really did well also
yeah you guys got to get these all on
blu-ray the blu-rays are fantastic
they're blu-rays are not expensive you
can get these blu-rays used in mint
condition for like three bucks delivered
off of ebay because they made so many of
them the only ones that I think this is
still expensive a Spectre expect to pay
about twenty bucks delivered for Spectre
yeah my two Spectre steelbook and it
comes in this kind of this matte black
it looks really cool they really did a
nice yeah but you guys got to get up to
speed on Spectre I see we got to get up
to speed on James Bond because the fifth
movies coming out soon funny cuz like I
said I'll go to the theater for that
yeah the original series of James Bond
was like I had seen most of them over
the years but you know it wasn't ever
like a favorite I was never like rushing
out to see them but these new ones are
really kind of something
special and I really kind of have to
admire that they were able to do that in
this day and age like make the character
relevant right I also want to owe all
four of the themes the Bond themes
because if you have theme song together
alright yeah all very good really good
which none of them are really a
traditional non know they do their own
not really but I like the [ __ ] that they
did with them yeah you know what I mean
so closest to a traditional Bond theme
song would have been sky sky fall the
Adele song yeah this is a beautiful song
but yeah that is the closest to a
traditional but they're all good
probably the most off-the-wall one was
the one from Quantum of Solace the
jacket white and Alicia Keys yeah yeah I
like I did too it's it's kind of the
strangest one I take all the sides like
a little bit of a 70s funky kind of
non-japanese [ __ ] kind of the thing with
rock and almost kind of a weird kind of
R&B kind of yeah
well Jack White has said that his
favorite Bond theme was on Her Majesty's
Secret Service so he kind of used that
as an inspiration I think one of the
weirdest ones is the one from Spectre
though that one's very kind of downbeat
and yeah ominous weird male kind of
operatic vocals yeah that's my Sam Smith
no but I like it which I didn't know
originally Radiohead were approached to
do the theme for Spectre they turned in
a song that they had written back in the
90s but had never produced they said now
we know like that then Radiohead wrote
another one that was just called Spectre
and the ironic thing was they didn't use
it because they thought it was too
melancholy but then the song that they
use was really about like oh yeah sure I
thought that was very odd all the right
really all the writing's on the wall in
a way and it's referring to the bonds
name being on the wall of dead agents
because as the movies continue all four
of them there's this sense of Bob's
running out of time and running out of
energy and he's running out of luck and
he's running out of everything yeah
that's like yeah it's kind of a
character that he's go ahead and towards
the grave it's a very life and death
theme do the whole for movies yeah yeah
and also we should mention the Chris
Cornell doing the theme for loved it
yeah that's a great song and like I said
that's a great song tied in with
yeah the animation of the theme sequence
exactly setting this sets the stage for
this new Bond series are you ready to
die are you ready to kill other people
are you ready to die for this because
that's where you're going
I've seen other people die and you ain't
[ __ ] compared to those people I saw die
so you gonna die and I love I love that
the song is called you know my name's
you know my name and he never says it
that the very end of the movie this is a
theme and then he says bond James Bond
do you want to be impressed just you can
look at that you could is really so much
thought put into it you can watch the
opening sequence for free on YouTube
with that song and you know my name like
you know Daniel Craig's face coming out
you know pretty cool but yeah I really
like it's really well thought out well
put together so you know kudos everyone
involved
and we're very excited for the new one
that's coming out wasn't coming out this
year or next year I think they said it
was 2019 okay and 2019 well say they
they usually like really keep it under
wraps yeah like they won't even tell you
what the name of it is they want any
what it's about they really which one is
based on or anything I wouldn't I would
say 2020 is probably when it will
actually yeah cuz I'm amazed that they
actually get this [ __ ] done with all the
with it with all the special effects
they have to build and they built all
those sets and all this other kind of
stuff they weren't going to do it that
the specter was supposed to be the last
one because there is the story ends
there is an ending pretty much it does
wrap up but there's a way to way to
bring it back and yeah very powerful way
of bringing about I read how they plan
to bring him back yeah yeah well I liked
it I mean they wrapped up the story they
left it a little open-ended so that if
they wanted to make another one they
could like it wouldn't just be stupid
that they had retcon but they but there
was also a natural wrap up if they
didn't make another one then they would
just be a container
well Spectre was not defeated so it was
not yeah so like I said they line out
they left it open yeah so we'll see how
that goes I think it's gonna be good
should be yeah so that'll do it for our
review of the Daniel Craig double O
seven movies check them out if you
haven't checked them out already like I
said watch them all in order because you
know if you'll you'll appreciate them a
lot more that way remember if you like
the show to like share subscribe and
share with all your friends if you'd
like to financially support the show you
can go to our patreon page at
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock or you can
go to our blog which is 13 o'clock
podcast wordpress.com and there's a link
in the sidebar to a PayPal account if
you'd like to make a one-time donation
also check out some of our new t-shirts
at WWE as well comm / 13 o'clock I just
added like four new ones so hopefully
they're up by the time this comes out
and that will do it for this latest
installment of our movie retrospective
series see you next time bye